the threat from Florence comes one year
after hurricane ARMA struck Florida
twice and caused tens of billions of
dollars in damages there of course
Rhonda Phil Keating is on Big Pine Key
tonight Carolinians are stocking up
buying plywood and emptying shelves
people in the Florida Keys are still in
recovery mode
my daughter had just moved into her
house even now emotions are raw for
charter boat captain Scott Leopold after
cat for Aramis slammed into the Florida
Keys one year ago today people like him
continue to struggle there are a number
of captain's that threw in the towel oh
my god we last met clay Crockett as he
walked into his house and catering
business to see for the very first time
what was left last time we couldn't even
walk into something irma cost him a few
hundred thousand dollars and he still
has a hole in his roof
I'd rather just keep trying to move
forward you know the last year has been
a very tough year much of the challenge
for the tourist dependent businesses was
the loss of thousands of hotel rooms
just last week the iconic hawks cay
resort finally reopened with more hotels
still to come last year Irma destroyed
one out of every four homes in the
Florida island chain making housing a
enormous challenge still to this day
especially affordable housing but now
these new elevated cottages built by the
Florida Keys Land Trust are starting to
come online and the list of people
hoping to move in to just the first
floor is long Brett Phil Keating live on
the keys tonight Phil thanks